the path forward the path towards
choosing connection is you have to
choose
love I remember asking a buddy who was
an active Navy SEAL you'll love each
other when you're out on deployment he
responded with a unique and special kind
of love it's a kind of love that will
lay your life down for somebody else who
will say if not me then who it's a love
that says all go first it's a love about
purpose love doesn't mean soft and love
doesn't mean weak and love doesn't mean
giving up your power and love doesn't
mean having no boundaries this is rooted
in Neuroscience love calms the body love
connects you are who you are in space
and within your own body because you are
connected or because you're disconnected
because you were loved or because you
were unloved